[Musik]
blut ist eine stadt im südwesten
frankreichs in den ausläufern der
pyrenäen sie ist auf der ganzen welt als
katholische marien wallfahrtsstätte
bekannt denn im jahr 18 58 soll ihr der
erst 14-jährigen bernadette maria die
mutter gottes erschienen sein
seither ist die quote der zentrale punkt
im heiligen bezirk von der quelle werden
heilkräfte zugeschrieben
und es wird von vielen wunderheilungen
berichtet
die jährlich stattfindende
internationale soldatenwallfahrt nach
wird entsteht 1958 aus einer gemeinsamen
friedensinitiative französischer und
deutscher militärseelsorger heute ist
sie die größte friedenskundgebung von
soldatinnen und soldaten aus
europäischen armeen österreichische
teilnehmer sind von beginn an dabei
in ihrer 62 auflage vom 12 16 bildern
rund 9000 soldatinnen und soldaten aus
37 nationen nach lord im zentrum steht
das gemeinsame gebet um den frieden aber
auch der austausch unter den soldatinnen
und soldaten ist ein wichtiger
bestandteil
es ist aber eine wallfahrt im schatten
der ereignisse in der ukraine ein
furchtbarer krieg mitten in europa wir
beten auch besonders für die menschen
und um dieses vom krieg so geplagte land
betont militärbischof werner freistetter
in seiner begrüßung der heimischen
pilgergruppe
heuer haben österreichische und
französische soldaten das internationale
zeltlager aufgebaut ein gemeinsamer
gottesdienst mit österreichischen und
schweizer pilgern unterstreicht die
besondere verbundenheit
für militärbischof werner freistetter
ist diese wallfahrt immer etwas
besonderes hier gibt es ja so viel zu
erfahren von freundschaft und
kameradschaft und begegnung bis zu
intensiver begegnung mit gott und mit
der mutter gottes
dieser ort ist einfach etwas besonderes
und ich freue mich dass es gelungen ist
diesen neuen anfang nach zwei jahren
pause wieder zu setzen
die teilnahme an der traditionellen
lichterprozession durch den heiligen
bezirk ist einer von mehreren
höhepunkten der tausenden soldaten
ein
der sonntag steht im zeichen der
internationalen messfeier in der
basilika
[Musik]
für bischofsvikar alexander wessel ist
die soldatenwallfahrt ebenfalls etwas
ganz besonderes ich glaube es ist
wirklich ein neuanfang wo wirklich alles
danieder gelegen ist und wo wir jetzt
wirklich wieder durchstarten können in
nationale und internationale kontakte um
kameradschaft zu pflegen und letztlich
auch kontakte und kameradschaft zu gott
zu pflegen hier diesen ganz besonderen
ort in frankreich
[Musik]
die abschlussfeier ist das offizielle
ende der militär wallfahrt und der
beginn neuer freundschaften über das
gebet und der wunsch nach frieden in der
welt erhört werden